like to ruin to ruin the perception i i
gotta ask how much
of of uh adult video is just faked
like right right it totally depends on
the work
sometimes we think we make a fake comp
yeah yeah right yeah yeah do you guys
say have you guys seen the
asa banana the product the drinking
product
it's like it's like it's like a banana
flavored jelly yeah yeah yeah
we actually used that for baking
squirted on you
yeah yes you know insert that with oh
i got to google this yeah because i
remember i'm never drinking that
yeah i remember we briefly talked about
this in the interview you were saying
that like a lot of the fake calm
is like the asana
[Laughter]
thank you very much as long as the [ __ ]
is grass-fed
i think my starbucks semi-semi-skimmed
[Laughter]
if an actor won't come in this scene
then you can still
use the actor in the next scene right
yeah you can save his company you can
save him the energy so
is that how hentai protagonists have
like just
so much come every time you know
something
is this why they're like all the dvds
are like three hours long
like they like save it because you when
you do like uh because they're like
they're really long
right like two hours is that in one day
or is that like a multiple day thing oh
usually just one day because
renting a studio is very expensive so is
it one is it one actor the entire time
uh it depends on but sometimes they just
change and they make it pob
so they won't find out sometimes yeah
because i've seen like
i've seen like i've seen like best of
eight hours long and
in my head i'm just like first of all
wow that's a long shoot
second of all who is gonna sit down and
watch eight hours obviously
it's giving me anxiety trying to find
the the best part right i'm like
like is it made for people with like
erectile dysfunction whereas it's like
it just takes
like give me two hours and i'll be there
like yeah i just i just don't understand
like
i know they seem to get the longer the
better the longer they're better yeah
wow that's like a youtube video i need
to get those mood rolls
i i i wonder did you like ever watch any
of your own work or did you just like
when you did it you're like i'm not
doing anything right
i mean during my career like i did watch
some of my cribs uh just for studying
for research
is it weird is it weird watching
yourself like at first i was it was so
embarrassing
the light doesn't really hit well
it's all wrong okay this angle isn't for
me
i love i love how you said that you
watched your own clips for research but
yeah that's the perfect word
good yeah
i mean i'm sure like we do that right on
on youtube like
we sometimes watch back on our old
videos i cringe like i i can't watch
myself on camera like
sometimes even on the podcast i'm i'm
just cringing i used to
and i think as you like get used to it
more yeah sometimes you're like damn
that was a good video
i love watching this hat on the back
like god damn i like job me
i look damn good funny joke comes up and
you're like damn that was a good joke
i remember this part yeah sometimes i
just laughed with the those like dirty
words i just said
that line was from this manga
i personally go old 2d when it comes to
like when you are on reduce yourself
i never watch porn you know yeah i go
for 2d